in the Shivering scene north of Essos
there are many queer tales of the
creatures that roam the frozen waters
how far this frozen vastness extends
none can say no man of Westeros has ever
sailed further east than the thousand
islands but men and women of the East
who have ventured too far north have
encountered treacherous howling winds
and enormous icebergs that could destroy
even the most well built ships and
frozen seas that extend on for miles and
miles
most who have tried to sail north
through the Shivering sea have perished
and many have tried those who lived have
returned south half-dead from frost and
the white waste called the Shivering sea
only grows larger in winter out of the
Shivering sea come whispers of the
cannibal Bay where ships are said to
enter only to find themselves trapped
forever when the sea freezes hard behind
them tales of dead men in the water
drowned spirits who rise at the night to
drag the living deep down into the
depths of the dark blue frozen sea
stories of pale blue mist that moves
across the waters mists so cold that any
ships that passed through it are frozen
instantaneously of course - there is
talk of merfolk pale gray of flesh with
black scales they are said to be far
more vicious than their cousins to the
south and none can forget the tales of
those enormous winget beasts said to be
made of living ice they possess eyes of
blue crystal and breath that is the
essence of cold the great ice dragons of
the Shivering sea it is said that an ice
dragons breath is a chill so terrible
that it can freeze a human solid in a
fraction of a second these beasts appear
to be direct counterpart
to the dragons of old Valyria other than
the fact that the size of an ice dragon
is said to be thrice that of the
Valyrian dragons whilst the dragons of
the fourteen flames were fire made flesh
these are ice made flesh some claim that
the tales of ice dragons are mere
fantasies stories made up by
superstitious sailors delusional and
half frozen but it was suggested by
archmaester Marr graped
that the many mentions of the cannibal
bay and the freezing blue mist could be
explained as warped reports of the
activity of ice dragons the way the ice
dragons are described in A Song of Ice
and Fire
is indistinguishable from the way they
are described in George RR Martin's
short story the ice dragon both
creatures are ice made flesh and melt
when slain it is known that sailors from
half a hundred nations have glimpse to
these cold monsters throughout the
centuries in the Shivering sea too many
reports not to be taken seriously many
sea creatures swim in the waters of the
Shivering sea a great beast such as an
ice dragon would have plenty of food to
feed on they're given George RR Martin's
recurring use of the ice dragon and the
title of this series itself it is not a
stretch to say that dragons of ice made
flesh will appear eventually in our
story
in a world of balance and cycles it
makes sense to have a direct counterpart
to the side of fire the balance must be
maintained it would be foolish not to
mention the others of legend here the
White Walkers like the ice dragons are
said to be made of living ice they ride
on the winds of winter white mist that
comes howling out of the north their
eyes are pale blue just like those of
the ice dragon could whatever power that
awakened the others in the land of
always winter have also birthed the ice
dragons could it be the same power that
is worshipped by the wildlings in the
far north the gods of snow and ice and
darkness whatever the truth it cannot be
denied that the magic of ice dragons is
described eerily similar to the magic of
the others whether the two are connected
can only be speculated though in my
opinion it is greatly suggested and as
for the merlynx and the drowned spirits
of the waters we know that the stories
of merlynx and deep ones exist
throughout the known world their
presence seems undeniable as for the
drowned spirits they seem to be a
reference to the Dead Marshes of JRR
Tolkien's lore but they may have been
mentioned in A Song of Ice and Fire
before the world of Ice and Fire
in jon snow's letter from hardhome
attempt to take the storm crow defeated
six crew dead many wildlings eight
ravens left dead things in the water
send help by lands seas racked by storms
how's it going guys I just wanted to
take this time to mention that I am
doing a giveaway of god emperor of dune
which is my favorite book in the series
all you need to do to qualify to win is
to comment on my most recent dune video
the ultimate guide to dune part 1 which
is part of a series of videos that I'm
doing right now I'm also giving away a
copy of David Lynch's dune on blu-ray
this is available only to patrons of one
dollar or more of course with patreon
you get access to tons of exclusive a
Song of Ice and Fire content that's not
on youtube so thanks for watching and
listening everyone peace out